I trained a neural net on this data and
it turned out the neural net I trained
was the most accurate model anyone could
train on this data set and then there
was a question you know would it
actually be safe for us to go ahead and
use this neural net on real patients and
I said you know I don't think we should
use this on real people and that's
because it's a black box we don't
actually understand what it's doing
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using in the
world of machine learning there's been a
notable trade-off between accuracy and
intelligibility either the models are
accurate but difficult to make sense of
or easy to understand but prone to error
that's why dr. rich Caruana principal
researcher at Microsoft Research has
spent a good part of his career working
to make this simple more accurate and
the accurate more intelligible today dr.
Caruana talks about how the rise of deep
neural networks has made understanding
machine predictions more difficult for
humans and discusses an interesting
class of smaller more interpretable
models that may help to make the black
box nature of machine learning more
transparent that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast rich Caruana welcome to the
podcast thank you great to have you here
today
great to be here you're a principal
researcher at MSR working with a broad
set of AI researchers who a lot of Venn
diagram overlap but you don't
necessarily as you say cluster to a
formal group but give our listeners an
idea of the big research questions
you're asking the big problems you're
trying to solve what gets you up in the
morning sure yeah there's a group of us
who don't necessarily cluster with other
activities in the lab first of all
machine learning research I've been
doing machine learning since grad school
in the 90s and I do a lot of machine
learning for healthcare so machine
learning where the problem of interest
has to do with predicting your risk or
as treatment for certain illnesses but I
do a lot of other things as well I do
some stuff in machine learning that's
just trying to make machine learning
better and then I work on some other
applications like machine learning being
used for ecological purposes for you we
do a lot of work in ornithology where
we're trying to track birds and things
like that let's talk a little bit more
about machine learning and the models
they're in there's historically been a
trade-off between accuracy and
intelligibility or interpretability
could you explain what that means and
why it matters
sure what's a scientist sent to us so
there are simple learning methods you
know think of linear regression logistic
regression these are very simple methods
they're applicable to many different
things
they're pretty intelligible because you
can just sort of see well it's this wait
times this feature plus this wait times
this feature unfortunately there's a lot
of complex models that can't be
represented so simply you really need a
much more complex function of the
features so and that would be modern
methods like boosted trees random
forests neural nets now deep neural Nets
so these things generate much more
complex functions and unfortunately the
penalty you pay for the extra accuracy
is they're much harder to open up and
understand I mean a modern deep neural
net can be hundreds of layers deep and
can have tens or hundreds of millions of
weights inside the model all of which
have been tuned by the learning process
on some data set that might itself have
you know a million or ten million
examples in it you're never gonna wrap
your head around ten million or 100
million weights and yet all of these
things work together to represent the
function that the thing has learned and
is going to use to make predictions so
that's much harder to understand than
linear regression which was just a
single wait times one of the features
plus another wait times another feature
so in in some domains if you don't have
much data or if the problems not very
hard
linear logistic regression is perfectly
adequate but there are lots of problems
that we're working on now since we have
so much data where you really need
something that's much more complex much
more accurate and unfortunately you tend
to lose intelligibility when you use
those models and there's a lot of work
being done now and trying to figure out
how do we open up these black boxes to
get some idea of what's going on inside
let's talk about the black box nature of
machine learning models and it's been a
given in the industry for a couple of
different reasons why would we run into
the black box yeah no that's a good
question so if you think back 3040 years
ago in AI when we were building things
like expert systems these were human
engineered systems that were trying to
do something very intelligent but they
were being crafted by humans and because
of that you could actually understand
exactly how they were supposed to work
most AI now is based on machine learning
and machine learning the way it works is
you collect a big data set possibly very
complex it might have 10,000 features in
it and a hundred thousand records in it
or or ten million records in it you
would have no idea how to manually craft
a very accurate rule for this sort of
problem domain so instead what we do is
we give that data set to what is
essentially a statistics engine that
sits there and looks for every pattern
it can find in those examples that seems
relevant for what you want to predict
and then it ends up learning this
complex function that captures all of
those statistical regularities that are
in the data set now the problem is you
didn't understand all the statistical
regularities in the data set to begin
with and it's not like the machine
learning told you what it was doing when
it train the model it just sort of
translates from here's a 10 million
records in a database to here's 10
million weights in a model and you kind
of have to use the model to make
prediction right so there's really not
been much opportunity to understand
what's been captured by the machine
learning process in fact it's kind of a
miracle that it works so well they learn
things in some cases that look like
things that are going on inside human
brains and other cases they learn
patterns that we didn't know about but
that once you see the pattern you
realize that's incredibly useful new
knowledge right in other cases they
learn the standard things which you
would have hoped that they would learn
and they maybe just learn it better than
humans know those statistics and then in
a few cases unfortunately they learn
things which are true patterns in the
data but there are mistakes for how
you're going to use the model and that's
where you'd love to be able to see
what's going on inside these models one
so you can learn from the good things
that they figured out because there
might be like new science you know new
discoveries hidden in the data but also
you'd love to be able to find the
smaller number of things where they've
made some mistakes that could make the
model less accurate or possibly even
dangerous if you were to deploy it so
you'd love to be able to see what's
going on inside the models to find these
mistakes and then have a chance of
fixing them I know that we've talked
about the distillation model approach to
solving some of these problems and
you've added transparency to that can
you unpack that right so we tend to use
transparency to mean that it's a model
that we really can understand it we can
open it up instead of black box it's
like clear box or something lucite box
yeah yeah yeah exactly lucite box I like
that
so transparency tends to mean we can see
what's going on inside and you got to be
careful with this so you know a neural
net that has a hundred million weights
in it if you give me all those weights
and you show me how they're connected
I could painfully slowly simulate
exactly what it
doing sure it's not that we don't know
what's going on inside I mean we write
the code for these things yes so we know
exactly what function is being computed
it's just not transparent in the sense
that it's being represented in a way
that's not a good match to how humans
think so we think of it as not being
transparent just because it's not
practical for us to understand it and
then what we do is we try to somehow
open up that box there are lots of cases
where you can't do that and instead what
we sometimes do is we we've started
training an intelligible model something
that's not as complex as a neural net to
mimic the neural net so if we can train
an intelligible model to mimic what was
learned by the neural net and then open
up the intelligible model that could
tell us something about what's going on
inside the neural net maybe we'll still
use the neural net at runtime to make
predictions but this gives us a sort of
window into the black box into that
complex neural net and maybe we can
understand that
[Music]
you mentioned something about the
proprietary nature or intellectual
property syndrome for the other reason
there's a black box what's that about
right so sometimes it's not the case
that the black box model is super
complex like some massive neural net
sometimes it's just a black box because
it's protected by IP so many people will
have heard of this model that is used
for recidivism predictions so this model
was created by a company and the model
is a pay for a use model and the model
is just not something that's known to us
because we're not allowed to know by law
it's a something the company owns and
the courts have several times upheld the
right of the company to keep this model
private so maybe you're a person who
this model has just predicted you're a
high risk of committing another crime
and because of that maybe you're not
going to get parole and you might say
hey I think I have a right to know why
this model predicts that I'm high risk
and so far the courts have upheld the
right of the company that created the
model to keep the model private and not
to tell you in detail why you're being
predicted as higher low risk now there
are good reasons for this you don't
necessarily want people to be able to
game the siRNA model and in other cases
you really want to protect the company
who went to the expense and risk of
generating this model but that's a very
complex question let's switch over to
the medical fields right now about the
same issue of collecting data giving you
a result that is like anyone who knows
anything would look at that result and
say that can't be right
tell us that story so back when I was a
graduate student my adviser Tom Mitchell
who's well known in the machine learning
community asked me to train a neural net
on a pneumonia dataset that he was
working with with a number of other
colleagues so I trained a neural net on
this data and guess I got lucky it
turned out the neural net I trained was
the most accurate model anyone could
train on this data set and then there
was a question you know would it
actually be safe
for us to go ahead and use this neural
net on real patients and I said you know
I don't think we should use this neural
net on real people and that's because
it's a black box we don't actually
understand what it's doing and what had
me concerned was a friend who was at
another university who was training on
the same data set but he was using rural
based learning he learned a role one
night that if you have a history of
asthma it lowers your chance of dying
from pneumonia that his asthma seems to
be protective you know for pneumonia and
he's like rich what do you think that
means and so he took it to the next
meeting there were real MDS involved in
this project and the MD said wow we
consider asthma to be a serious risk
factor for people who now have pneumonia
so we don't want your model to predict
that asthma is good for you that's a bad
thing right but we can kind of see how
that might be a real pattern in the data
you know asthmatics are paying attention
to how their breathing they probably
noticed the symptoms of pneumonia
earlier than most people would you know
they have a healthcare professional who
probably treats their asthma so they're
already plugged into healthcare so
they're gonna get an appointment and
they're gonna get earlier diagnosis that
in fact what they have is not an asthma
related problem but that they've got
pneumonia and because they're considered
high-risk patients they're actually
going to get really high quality you
know aggressive treatment they're going
to get it sooner than other people
because they're paying more attention so
and it turns out if you've got an
infection there's nothing better than
getting like rapid diagnosis and rapid
treatment so it turns out the asthmatics
actually have almost half the chance of
dying of the non asthmatics
it's not because the asthma is good for
them but it's because they get to
healthcare faster and they get to
treatment faster right
and the problem is that the rule based
system learned this rule that asthma is
good for you I assume a neural net that
I trained on exactly the same day to
learn the same pattern that asthma looks
good for you but if we're going to use
that model to go out and intervene in
your healthcare and we deny the
asthmatics the sort of rapid high
quality care that made them low risk
then we'll actually be possibly harming
asthmatics
and what I told them was I said my
neural net probably has this asthma
problem in it that doesn't worry me
because I can probably figure out how to
make that problem go away what really
scares me is what else did the neural
net learn that's similarly risky but the
rule-based system didn't learn it and
therefore I don't have a warning that I
have this other problem in the neural
net and now flash forward to the present
we now have a new class of interpretable
models that we've been developing here
at Microsoft the last seven years that
is just as accurate as this neural net
so this trade-off between accuracy and
intelligibility for certain kinds of
problems now is gone we can get all that
accuracy out of this new kind of model
but it's just as easy to understand as
the linear based system as linear
regression in fact in many ways it's
better than linear regression from an
interpretability point of view and it
turns out when we train the model on
that data set it of course learns that
asthma is good for you as we expected
that was the first thing I checked yeah
it learns that heart disease and chest
pain are good for you because you also
get quick aggressive treatment exactly
if you've had a heart attack say a year
or two ago
and now you wake up in the morning and
your breathing feels a little funny your
chest doesn't feel quite right within an
hour you're in an ambulance or you're at
the ER and even at the ER you get pushed
to the head of the line you know you're
in a bed really fast and they're trying
to figure out if you're having a heart
attack and what they should do and then
they have good news it's like oh you're
not having a heart attack
it's just pneumonia and then because
you're still at higher risk if you've
had two heart disease in the past
they'll give you a very aggressive
treatment again so it turns out the
model thinks that heart disease is even
better for you than asthma and that's
because the heart disease patients are
the ones who get to the hospital fastest
so they're having a problem and then
they get high quality treatment and that
treatment is usually effective okay so
tell us about the model that you're
referring to that you've quote-unquote
fixed this problem sure so what we've
done is we've taken a class of models
called generalized additive models these
are often called gams statisticians
invented these in the
late 80s so these are models that have
predate a lot of machine learning and
these models were created in part
because statisticians wanted models that
would be you know complex enough to fit
the data but interpretable but
statisticians tend to fit models with a
lot of emphasis on smoothness and
simplicity like a statisticians basic
way of thinking is I will not add that
term to my model unless I'm 95%
confident it really has to be there
right right so these are the people who
brought us T tests and confidence
intervals and things like that and they
take them very seriously what we've done
now is we've taken this class of
generalized additive models that
statisticians invented long ago and
we're now using kind of machine learning
steroids you know modern computer
science modern machine learning to fit
them in a way where they don't have to
be as simple and smooth as they used to
be by letting them be more complex we're
able to get a lot more accuracy out of
them than statisticians were getting out
of them and then by getting more
accuracy out of them they're turning out
to be more interpretable because they're
just doing a better job of modeling the
real phenomena in the data it's just the
same class being done a new way that is
making them reach levels of performance
both accuracy and interpretability that
they hadn't achieved before I mean kind
of go in different directions short for
a second but part of this is about the
correlation causation problem talk about
that a little bit and how the research
you're doing can help us maybe overcome
some of these errors that we get sure
and in this correlation causation
question is the fundamental question in
the kinds of models we're talking about
when we say having asthma having art
disease are good for you those are true
statistical patterns in the data like it
really is true that the patients with
heart disease have a better chance of
surviving and not because of the heart
disease but not because of the heart
disease it's because of the way those
patients are treated in society it's
because the patient is worried they take
it seriously the patient gets to
healthcare and then health care takes it
very seriously so they get very wrapped
treatment we would love the model to be
learning the causal effect we would love
the model to figure those things out
suppose our model even that neural net
was going to be used by an insurance
company just to sort of decide what your
chance of living or dying because if
you're gonna live then they have to keep
money in the bank to pay for your
healthcare next year right
well that company might find it very
interesting that part disease patients
actually have less chance of dying from
pneumonia and presumably more chance now
of dying from something else but an
insurance company since they're not
going to intervene they're less
concerned about the causal question
they're just interested that it's
predictively
accurate it's only when you're going to
intervene in somebody's health care and
possibly change things like time to care
aggressiveness of treatment whether
they're hospitalized or not hospitalized
it's only when you're going to do that
that you're really interested in the
causal questions
[Music]
you talked to me about the
teacher-student model and mimicry in
machine learning and some of the new
things that you're discovering can you
talk to our listeners about that too
sure sure so let's see I'll go way back
a grad student at Madison University in
the early 90s about the time I was doing
my PhD did this interesting thing where
he trained a decision tree to mimic a
neural net and that's because a neural
net wasn't very easy to understand but a
decision tree could be understood about
15 years ago when I was at Cornell we
ended up using this trick for a
different purpose so there we were
training these massive ensembles of
models and ensemble just means that we
have a thousand models all of which vote
to make a collective decision and that
often makes the models more accurate the
ensembles were so big they were too slow
to use for many purposes so we wondered
is there a way that we could make them
faster and then what we did was we use
this mimicry trick we would train a
small fast model to mimic the
predictions made by the very big
ensemble and to our surprise we could
often get that to work that is we could
get a small model to be just as accurate
as that massive ensemble and then the
small model would be a thousand times
faster in a thousand times smaller so
that was great and then coming to the
present these deep neural Nets just sort
of keep getting deeper and bigger when
they were just three or four or five
hidden layers they weren't too crazy
bigger or expensive to run but then they
started getting to be 20 layers and then
50 layers and then 100 layers they got
to the point where they were massive it
turns out the deepest neural Nets just
wouldn't run fast enough to be able to
do this so we started doing work where
we would compress these very deep neural
Nets into shallower neural Nets so we
could actually you know in the lab over
the last month we would train that
monster deep neural net which was super
accurate and then the following month we
would figure out how to compress it into
a much smaller neural net that was going
to be much faster and would be something
fast enough we could actually run it in
production and use it and get still most
of the accuracy of the monster model
that we
too big for us to use so that's a trick
that people now use to make neural nets
deep very big deep neural nets be more
practical does it have a name I called
it a model compression okay and geoff
hinton another well-known researcher in
deep learning called it distillation I
like to use the word compression when
our goal is to make the model smaller
and faster but I'd like to use the word
distillation when our goal is to take
what was learned by model a and somehow
put it into model B so I like Jeff
Hinton's term distillation there and now
what we're doing is we're using
distillation to make black box models
more interpretable and we do exactly
this mimicry trip so we you have trained
some monster deep neural net and what
we'll do is we'll try to train some form
of interpretable model like the models
that we've been working on the last
seven years to mimic that deep neural
net and then we open up our more
interpretable model because it's easy to
see what's inside of it and it can tell
us a lot of things about what's going on
inside that big black box model it's not
a perfect technique yet but it's so far
it seems to work surprisingly well again
better than we expected so you're
calling the big model the teacher and
the little model the student and the
student is learning to mimic the teacher
that's exactly right so it's sometimes
called teacher-student training mimicry
I think is a good way to describe it so
that's kind of an apprentice let's talk
about MSR and the nature of research
that's going on here you and I talked a
bit about the serendipity of being able
to have some academic freedom and the
discovery process that comes out of that
in sometimes surprising ways talk about
the climate here the nature of
interdisciplinary research among
researchers and teams and so on and what
you like about it
sure so I came to Microsoft Research o
or maybe eight years ago and you know I
had to figure out well what are the
things that I want to work on here at
MSR and as an individual contributor I
have a lot of freedom in deciding what
to work on and one of the things that
had always been bugging me was this
problem I had run into in the 90s where
I trained the most accurate model on a
medical data set but then I was the one
who said no we shouldn't use it and that
always kind of bothered me it's like if
I'm going to do machine learning in
healthcare you know I have to solve this
problem so that we can use these very
accurate models and you know safely so I
had some crazy idea and I got an intern
from Cornell where I had been a
professor and explained the crazy idea
and the intern thought oh that's a cool
idea let's work on that and it just
turned out to be better than we thought
and so now I've been working on this say
seven years and at some point you know
my boss even said oh are you still
working on that yeah and I said yeah I
think it's important I think it's
valuable and then the world a fairness
and transparency out in the real world
suddenly became very important and it
turned out that we had what is maybe the
best algorithm for being able to
understand whether your model is biased
and trying to fix that bias so because
of that it's suddenly gotten to be very
important in the fairness and
transparency community and now now I
have two more interns working on it and
and you know we're trying to get some
developer resources to make better
quality code so that we can release the
code to the world so it's one of these
things where you know a problem I
stubbed my toe on in the late 90s it
seems to be bearing fruit and now it's
actually of much more interest
than I would have imagined in an area
that you might not know exactly so in
fact now one of the interns is Sarah is
an expert in fairness and transparency
machine learning she also does machine
learning for healthcare but she has a
lot of expertise in the fairness and
transparency community so now you know
could be half of our research is now
these sorts of models for fairness and
transparency and Microsoft is very
interested in these questions about how
do we make sure that the models were
training and using aren't biased turns
out this is of growing importance in
valuing the company and it's all a sort
of you know kind of accidental lowing
the path yeah yeah it's like exactly not
every project I do by the way you know
is so successful sometimes I have crazy
ideas and they just turn out eventually
to be crazy ideas and I've been lucky in
that I've had a lot of freedom here at
MSR to sort of explore these different
ideas and you know a good number of them
pan out but sometimes they pan out in
ways that we just didn't anticipate when
we started them and and that's great I
mean you know good science often does
that I asked all the researchers that
coming you've actually kind of already
answered what keeps you up at night but
is there anything else that you're
thinking of even now that might fall
into that same category right so there
is one thing even related to this
project which falls into that category
which is data can represent patterns
that are true patterns in the world but
they're actually not good patterns for
the way you plan to use the model and
sometimes in some domains the risk is
low and the value of accuracy is such
that you're willing to go and do this
especially if you have strong belief
that the test set really does look like
the real world you're going to deploy
the model into but in other domains you
know healthcare for example this is
clearly risky the cost is high and the
odds of existing health care having
fooled your model in some ways like by
making it think that asthma and heart
disease is for you you know is pretty
high because healthcare is a well-tuned
large system that's been running for
decades so they have a lot of expertise
and all the data you're going to get has
been affected by them
so that means your model is gonna learn
some things that are wrong and high
accuracy on a test set isn't safe and
that's because the test set looks just
like the training set right so it
actually gets rewarded with extra high
accuracy so you might look at the model
and say wow it's superhuman accuracy we
should go use it but it's superhuman
because it's cheating a little bit and
if we actually fix these things the
model is now less accurate on the test
data but we believe it would be more
accurate safer to use in the real world
and that's because we don't think the
test data is actually a perfect match
for what the world is going to look like
when we deploy it well these are things
to keep you up at night not necessarily
to give you nightmares but to give more
research opportunity to the next
generation as we close do you have any
parting wisdom parting advice to your 25
year old self oh oh that's interesting
um one thing that's good is there used
to be this saying back in the early days
of AI you should always work on the part
of the system that worries you the most
because there's a good chance that
that's the fundamental bottleneck in the
long run and if you don't solve it early
it's just gonna come back and haunt you
later on and I think in research I found
the thing that bothers me the most is
often the best thing for me to work on
someone once told me it's just as hard
to work on a hard problem as it is to
work on an easy problem so why not work
on the hard problems like why not work
on the ones that really matter and I
like to make sure that at least some of
the things I'm doing are things that
really worry me and that I don't really
have a good answer for and every now and
then you get lucky and you hit one of
those out of the ballpark for most of us
that only happens you know if we're
lucky once in our career maybe twice in
our career so it's really nice to make
sure you're working on some things which
just seems sort of fundamental and hard
and challenging and you're just not sure
that there's any immediate progress or
payoff that's going to come from it so I
definitely encourage people to have a
mix of things they're working on at
least one or two that they think is sort
of fundamental rich Caruana
thanks for joining us on the podcast
today sure thanks for inviting me and
this was great thank you to learn more
about dr. rich Carmona and how machine
learning research is making AI more
intelligible and interpretable visit
microsoft.com
[Music]